every time Jordan visits Italy he rents
a red Fiat in Florence and drives south
through Tuscany he'd always driven alone
until now this is a Fiat Cinquecento
1962 I've been in small cars in my life
this is the smallest car I've ever been
in this car would fit in the glove
compartment of my car in America I don't
think it's safe it doesn't clearly have
airbags and it's a windbag you see
you've come into this with a
predisposition about what a car should
be a light travel should be this is a
road trip this is the trip this is the
high point of the trip it's not about
the destination it is the journey you
think you're saying profound things but
most of what you say is the kind of
stuff a 15 year old girl writes into
yearbook I think Yoda writes half your
dialogue vacation begins in your mind it
understand that this car may not have
modern conveniences that you're used to
but like I said as humans we don't need
much putting keep refer to us as humans
only an alien talks that way I think
it's the value to step outside yourself
and examine yourself from the objective
standpoint outside there's so too much
static what I like to do is drive around
here I have very specific music that I
like to listen to them for example the
second verse let's say a little Tamar a
by a variable of jellyfish Donna guess
what I looked into it to play that music
would cost us a lot of money so I had
the band making us up some music it
doesn't cost us anything they see this
sounds are very stereotypical to the old
to the point of insulting when to the
sound effects Department I brought some
sound effects you wanna listen to those
but we can also have silence as well
I'm sorry signore Jordan but we don't
have the exact kind of wine that you
wanted is that ok you're gonna like this
one
[Applause]
oh the car
[Music]
[Applause]
that sound effects of a car peeling out
you're presuming that peeling out would
be superior
[Applause]
keep the emergency brake on yeah well
the Mersey brakes on I don't even think
that that's a brake lever I think that's
a breadstick this car is a toy it's a
pastry we're driving around basically in
an old walnut and we are stuck on a hill
every time you try and start the car we
roll backwards think about getting this
car started and be very careful with
your valuable conan payload can you stop
the car % stop it yeah just one other
thing yeah desiccated epidemic you know
and intellect and you're full you know
all your training has led you to this
yes
[Music]
great I love how mellow they are their
Torah emulate them I'm trying to enjoy
the simple life I'm trying to bask in
the Sun and enjoy the feeling of the
looks on you just poured that dog you
started talking
show that on replay you started to talk
I could get out and push it I think the
battery's dead
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes yes go go go okay that was good you
did well
oh you see what happens when you put the
sound effects down and you do something
constructive you have a memory we have
an experience if you lecture me the
parts are coming back
[Applause]
you